gonna be good doing a gig here in the
summer at this iconic venue would you
have ever thought when you first got
together 55 years ago that you'd still
be performing together today
no no quite simply no no we
we didn't used to think we'd last till
the end of the month or even
no i think that's the end of the week
that's the kind of band we were
i was very anxious to get get it all
over with and go back to uh art school
where the girls were beautiful
how do you keep that creative spark
alive though and still make music over
55 years
oh i'm never more alive than when i'm
singing
i'm not the writer of the song's beat is
but
there's something about climbing into
his music
for me as a as the kind of
the portal that communicates it with
people
i i never feel more man i'm sucking up
to you
get away now i never feel more than
more alive than when i'm doing that it's
kind of
it's it's absolute freedom it's
wonderful
obviously your lineup has changed over
the years as anything would
that runs for so long but does that mean
that the band is naturally evolving the
different characters the different
talents
yeah yeah i think the thing about the
the band that we have at the moment is
we've been through periods where we've
hand-picked people very carefully and
we've
actually employed quite a few lunatics
again
because we were used to having lunatics
in the band and we've ended up now with
a band
that allows i think are just teasing
roger about me in the front man when we
go on now it feels like roger and me
and that we're supported by the
musicians around us they don't
crowd in to try to you know get their
moment there's no competition
it feels as though it's honest that you
know the two
original members that are left roger and
i we're battling a way to kind of remain
relevant and to do good work
both on stage and off you know so
uh it feels right to me what we're doing
at the moment you know
roger decided to have a punt at doing an
orchestral thing here and it will be
interesting to see how it works in a
stadium like this you know i'm sure it
would be great
but uh you know we still perform very
much in the same way
as we used to do it's just it's just the
two of us now really
talk about the relationships working so
closely in a band together
obviously you guys spit up in the 80s
and then got back together
how do you set your differences aside
working so closely with your
we didn't ever really split up i mean it
was a
kind of unnecessary
departure for a few years because we had
problems to solve
musical problems in the band um
but we got over it pete and i i you know
it runs deep together and i don't think
that
you know we we it's been said we split
up in 1982 within
i just announced that we were this was
going to be our last tour
because i was very worried about pete at
the time because he'd just come out of a
very
bad
alcoholic and all kinds of stuff you
were on at that time with
all kinds of naughties uh and then he
cleaned himself up and i thought if we
go back on tour and keep doing this he's
gonna kill him and i
you know i love him i don't want that to
happen
so there's all things that go on but it
doesn't mean that
we've split up you know and it never
meant
i think my relationship our relationship
as
as friends and as co-workers
it's not an intimate one it's not you
know we when we travel on the stage we
don't spend on the road we don't spend a
lot of time together
i think what makes it interesting for us
both
is that this feels very much like work
it feels like what we've actually
found almost by accident you know what
for me was
almost like a school band when we first
got together
was some kind of dynamic that allowed us
to find jobs you know i
i wanted to be an artist in art but you
know what i found was writing
songs for the who there could be no
better job
that you know what i'm saying i had an
audience i had you know a band to write
for it a great voice in roger
and uh and so i feel it's always felt to
me like work it feels like we're
co-workers
and when we get together you know
there's also that thing about
carrying the history that we do it kind
of imposes and interposes interpolates a
bit of magic
you know nothing to do with us when we
went to play in south america
the first time a couple of years back
what was interesting about that and
mexico was that the kids
sort of knew us through youtube videos
of us who were much much younger
you know they were kind of going ah but
they weren't screaming at us they were
sort of screaming at who
used to be they were screaming at who we
used to be
times have changed so much don't they
the way people consume music like you're
saying youtube
it's all different and the chemistry
between us music you know musically when
we're on stage it's
it's telepathic it's kind of there's a
there's something in the air that is
untangi you know you can't put a finger
on it as such
but we know i know it's there between
peter and
we turn on a dime without any
even looking at each other and it just
happens
it's magical like a married couple
[Laughter]
you guys of course are making new music
but
do the fans always want the old stuff do
you will you ever get sick of singing my
generation
generation no no no i don't mind my
generation because it's always
you can always get off with someone in
the audience to sing it to
uh then i'm only the only song i've ever
got a little bit bored with and i don't
know why it won't get fought again and
that's been really honest
all the others i love i never get and i
try and take myself
back to the first day i ever sung the
song
in the first place every time i sing
them but for some reason
when i get to won't get thought again i
kind of drift off
and maybe it's because we play it yeah
playing it at the end of the show and
i'm thinking
i won't want long now i'm being a hot
bath with a cup of cocoa
the water bottle tucked up with me teddy
i'm sure that's not the case
obviously music has changed so much but
rock music right now
who is the who of this generation do you
think you've got you've got artists of
your caliber now there are a lot of
artists who
who the difficulty with all music not
just rock music
it's is that so much has been done you
know when we started in
sort of 63 64 you know there were a lot
of bands around a lot of bands who've
lasted you know from the beach boys the
beatles the rolling stones and
you know eric clapton jimi hendrix there
were some fantastic people around
but that's just a handful i mean today
there are hundreds of thousands of
artists producing music and getting it
out
and i think what actually happens is
it's very very difficult to come up with
anything that's
new novel has a different
feeling different sound different slant
to it different chords
you know you've got this thing with ed
sheeran being accused of copying marvin
gaye
you know you know because there are
there's only so many notes and so many
chords that you can use
in pop music you know it's true even of
classical music where
you know orchestral composers from from
the
17th and 18th century used to accuse
each other of stealing the music
you know because it all sounded the same
back then actually
so i think it's very difficult for a
rock band to come up with anything brand
new but yeah
1975 they're a great band i love them
yeah
the other thing is also is the
algorithms
which are run in the kind of streaming
sites
and uh it's so hard to for
music as such because the algorithms
they'll choose what's on
spotify or any of those sites by the
length of the intro and if the intro is
too long that goes in the bin
music on the basis of what you listened
to last time
so you don't necessarily get to hear new
stuff that's what i don't know he
loves to write long intros and i love
long intros because it gives the singer
a break
so i could have a flag
i know but more and more and more
you know bots and algorithms are
interfering with the music business and
it's
it's kind of tragic in a way me too
movement in the last year has totally
changed the face of acting
do you think rock music is going to have
its moment yep
it's coming day of reckoning yep
i do think the me too movement has been
fantastic and i know i don't know that
everybody agrees with me but i think
it's been fantastic i don't know
that it's been fantastic if you like for
the actresses that have been involved
because they're up there in the
forefront they have to
you know they have to fight their
battles but i do think that you know
it has been a a long time coming you
know i've been involved for years in
in helping people that have suffered
particularly women but
men too have suffered as young people
from
bullying from from beatings from sexual
abuse from all kinds of things you know
people get deeply deeply deeply damaged
and scarred by it
and i know some actresses i won't
mention their names because they're very
very close to me that have been through
this you know and harvey
uh weinstein was a friend of mine you
know he i was involved with him
i was i did the music for his first film
and he gave my daughter
her first job in the movie industry you
know she was a runner
you know not an actress so it was a real
shock to see what happened
and it was him that started it i think
it's a good
thing god knows what's going to happen
to him but it's a good thing
you've seen it from the inside finally
very last one uh
brexit it looks like it's getting
further and further away
is it going to be bad for british rock
music
no do the rock
like being governed by fifa